“Something which has never occurred since
time immemorial; a young woman did not fart
in her husband's lap.” That was the world’s
oldest recorded joke, first told in 1900 BC
in what is now southern Iraq. Obviously, toilet
human was just as popular back then as always.
The joke itself may not be very funny now,
but in 1900 BC it would have caused people
to crease up with laughter. But why? How come
when we’re told a joke or when someone falls
over or when we’re just in an awkward situation
– this strange gargled, grunting noise comes
out your mouth? What on earth is laughter
and why do we do it? Let’s find out.
Laughter is the most universal form of communication.
Unlike language which can just as easily divide
people, laughter brings people together. And
unlike language, everyone in the world understands
laughter. And when I say everyone I mean everyone,
because human beings are born with the ability
to laugh, we don’t learn to laugh, it’s
a basic human instinct.
Laughter is powerful, it can create powerful
bonds between individuals. Laughter is often
a part of the human mating ritual as well.
And some people even believe laughter can
heal you. Oh, and laughter can also be a force
for evil, but we’ll get to that later.
One of the most surreal aspects of laughter
is that, apart from fake laughter, we don’t
decide when to laugh, it just comes naturally.
This is strong evidence that there’s a good,
causational reason why humans laugh - such
a natural and instinctive trait doesn’t
just come along by accident.
But here’s the kicker. What if I told you
that laughing has nothing to do with a person’s
sense of humour? When we laugh it’s not
just because the other person told us a joke
that fits in with our taste in comedy, in
fact we laugh for a completely different reason.
Laughter isn’t about humour, it’s all
about being social, it’s about fitting in
and accepting others.
In a study that was carried out over a ten-year
period it was observed that most laughter
does not follow a joke. In fact, the researchers
observed that when a joke is told the person
telling the joke is much more likely to laugh
that the recipients of the joke. The vast
majority of laughter actually follows simple
statements and questions such as “Hey John,
where ya been?” and “How did you do on
the test?”. They don’t sound particularly
funny and that’s because they’re not.
In these situations, people laugh, not because
the statement is funny but because it helps
to strengthen social bonds.
Laughter is a means of acceptance of what
the other person is saying – a way of demonstrating
that you’re both “on the same page”,
without having to use a single word. Laughter
is a way to show the other person that you
appreciate what they’re telling you. It
can demonstrate that you like someone and
is sometimes used to diffuse awkward situations.
You’re thirty times more likely to laugh
when other people are around than when you’re
alone. Which just goes to show that laughter
is much more about bonding than humour. You’re
also more likely to laugh when you’re with
your friends as opposed to strangers. Because
you’re more inclined to bond with your friends.
It’s believed that laughter evolved from
the panting behaviour of our primate ancestors.
If you tickle an ape or gorilla, they will
produce an exuberant panting noise. That noise
is a primate’s version of laughter. But
not all animals laugh, so far we’re only
aware of two animals that laugh, apes and
rats. But there may be others that share this
ability, so get out there and start tickling
random creatures.
It’s believed the reason that primates evolved
the ability to laugh is because it was an
effective means of communication and a way
to strengthen bonds with their fellow beings,
long before the inception of language.
Apes can often be seen tickling each other
whilst playing, all the while laughing, although
from our perspective it would appear to be
joyful panting. If you’ve ever observed
this behaviour you will notice that before
long the entire troop of apes will be merrily
panting in unison. This is because laughter
is incredibly contagious.
In fact, a great way to make someone laugh
is just start laughing yourself. Although
this works remarkably better if your own laughter
is real, not faked. The human brain is unbelievably
good at telling the difference between fake
laughter and real laughter.
Laughter is so contagious that in 1962 in
Tanzania there was a laughter epidemic. It
all started when three girls started laughing
in a school in Kashasha. Before long the entire
school was erupting in fits of laughter. It
was so bad that the school had to close. The
laughter soon spread to neighbouring villages
and before long it had affected hundreds of
people. The laughing plague lasted for a staggering
eighteen months after is started. In total
over a thousand people were infected with
non-stop laughing for days on end and people
reported symptoms such as pain, flatulence,
attacks of crying and random screaming. Laughter
sure is a powerful thing.
But with great power comes great responsibility.
For laughter can be used for evil. It’s
true, there’s a dark side to laughter. Remember
when bullies would laugh in the playground
whilst causing another person upset and misery.
That’s because scientists believe there
are two kinds of laughter. The first is spontaneous
laughter, that’s the kind when we laugh
with our friends or when someone tells us
a joke. The other kind of laughter, non-spontaneous
laughter, includes fake laughter, nervous
laughter and evil cackling, the kind of laughter
you might hear from a villain in a James Bond
film.
Psychologists believe that this kind of laughter
is used to show superiority and dominance
over another. When militants and gangs attack
people they have often been witnessed to laugh
whilst doing it. But why? Someone being violently
attacked is certainly no laughing matter.
It’s believed that laughter is used in such
circumstances to form a bond between the attackers
and to exclude the victim, making them feel
isolated and therefore frightened. Laughter
helps to assert the attacker’s dominance
and makes them feel more powerful.
So to summarise, when we laugh we are accessing
and utilising an ancient evolutionary communication
system, that not only helps to create relationships
with other humans but to also maintain and
strengthen them. We can also use it to regulate
emotions, show dominance over others and even
to create fear.